hello there how much do you think you
know about fortnite well i have 69 facts
for you to hear and i want to know how
many you really know please like and
subscribe because i'd like to do more of
these videos and if you'd like to
support me this is my code my name is
adam maru let's go
did you know there's a physical version
of fortnite out in the world a super
limited run of disks were printed back
in 2017. if you have an unopened copy
it's worth over 1 500 right now and a
standard version is worth about a
hundred dollars in 50 years these could
be worth 10 000
so keep it safe if you have one the name
battle royale is in homage to a movie
which spawned the genre a cult japanese
film in which a class of students are
thrown onto an island and forced to off
each other until only one survives it's
really good you should watch it it has a
sequel too the youngest person to ever
be banned from fortnite was nine years
old xenon was given a four-year ban from
competitive fortnite due to being
underage what made it worse was all this
happened live on stream hearing xenon
cry as his dad comforts him is truly
heartbreaking did you know that each
chapter of fortnite has a gravestone
added to mark something a community
member has done during chapter one
shouty australian muselk accidentally
eliminated a player with a golf cart
whilst trying to rescue him epic placed
a gravestone to commemorate this and
added tyres to help anyone stuck there
in the future in chapter 2 a player
accidentally swam off the waterfall and
completely missed the water below
eliminating themselves epic again placed
a gravestone to mark his passing this
means now in chapter 3 you could be the
next person to be immortalized for
stupidity let me know if you become
fortnite famous from this epic games has
always been open to suggestions from its
community and has done some crazy things
to help them out in chapter one a note
could be found on a set of draws in the
house near greasy grove this was an
invite to prom from a player called eric
who wanted to combine the two things he
loved i hope she said yes when fortnite
hit mobile phones kids couldn't stop
playing it including in lessons at
school a teacher used reddit to get in
touch with epic to ask them to add a
message to his students and they did mr
hillman says stop playing in class was a
random loading screen you could see on
mobile recently skilled designers have
seen their creations added to fortnite
with credit of course but back in the
early days things were a little
different one kid named connor designed
a chicken trooper and epic loved it so
much it was added to the game as the
tender defender this is now commonplace
but back then this was a humongous
achievement other things added thanks to
suggestions include thanking the bus
driver something so simple but it began
life as a petition before epic said yeah
okay the rise of fortnite battle royale
led to the fall of other games such as
paragon a multiplayer only battle arena
when epic made the decision to turn off
the service for paragon it freely gave
away all the assets in the game so if
you are a budding developer you can use
10 million dollars worth of assets
totally free not many people know this
but paragon has a super rare banner in
fortnite players who had both games
before paragon was shut down forever
received this beauty and i have it so i
feel special limited edition banners
were also given to creators which is why
muzelk has his own logo on his back
bling i didn't get one because at the
time i only had 2 000 subscribers by the
way like and subscribe speaking of epic
games older franchises did you know a
bunch of them can be found in game over
the years the rust lord wears a pin
badge with a u on it representing the
unreal engine which fortnite created and
updates in fact almost every game you've
ever played was likely made in epics
unreal engine low texture posters and
pictures can be found around the world
such as jazz jackrabbit an old action
platformer from epic games we have
unreal tournament and the facing worlds
map a first person shooter which only
90s kids remember there's also shadow
complex an old xbox live arcade
platformer and one more there's this one
it looks like mortal kombat for mex the
game was called one must fall it was it
was dreadful the unreal engine and
fortnite share another bond fortnight
back in 2017 was the first game to ever
be developed for the unreal engine 4.
and then it happened again fortnite
became the first game to be developed on
the next engine unreal 5. here's another
90s reference you may have missed the
milk carton found in many kitchens is
taken from a music video coffee and tv
by brit pop band blur these changed over
the years there are still one or two you
can find the fortnite developers will
even reference themselves did you know
that the island in the center of the
chapter 2 map was shaped to be exactly
the same dimensions as the original
chapter 1 island extremely subtle and i
never noticed this until i was told last
week speaking of the islands do you know
their names chapter one is called athena
chapter two is apollo and chapter three
is artemis all of these names are taken
directly from greek mythology athena is
named after the greek goddess of wisdom
war weaving and crafts apollo is the god
of archery music and the sun and then
there's artemis who is the twin sister
of apollo the goddess of hunting
wilderness animals and the moon oh and
chastity did you know the first player
to reach 100 000 eliminations was hd
high distortion who pips ninja to this
world record i checked the stats again
and as i'm saying this right now the
current player with most elims is called
ship 354 361 elims they probably have
more now though ship also holds the
record for most fortnight wins all 32
635 of them disgusting and if you wanted
to know who has the most time played in
fortnite it's someone called prime salad
who has played for over 629 000 minutes
that's
437 days of non-stop fortnite i'm not
sure if that's impressive or that guy
just needs a hug the record for the
longest game of fortnite was won by one
of the x2 twins the game lasted one hour
52 minutes and 48 seconds the longest
heal off in history ninja has his own
record to be proud of the first pickaxe
added for a creator was ninja and the
plunger pickaxe he begged epic to make a
new cosmetic item to buy and suggested a
katana and a plunger as a joke epic made
the joke a reality the first creator to
have something added to the battle pass
was cdn iii his positivity emblem was
embraced by epic who wanted to share it
with the entire community another
creator cipher pk had an in-game item
added too a book at his favorite drop
spot to represent the playbook as he
taught fortnite players to be less
useless hut watch the long running
series from playstation grenade oh
that's me hut watch was officially added
to the files during chapter 2 as a new
building was erected near kathy corner
epic games was partially bought out by
chinese company 10 cent in 2013. they
paid 330 million dollars for 40 of epic
games right now epic is worth more than
30 billion dollars meaning 10 cents
investment has made them around 12
billion dollars wow the key reason 10
cent was allowed to join was to get epic
and their games into the chinese
demographic but that hasn't gone so well
firstly all skulls were removed from
fortnite due to it being highly
inappropriate in china then the chinese
government limited the number of hours
children could play games and made
monetization close to impossible so epic
and tencent pulled the plug r.i.p
fortnite china back in fortnite chapter
1 toilet down at flush factory could
change color representing
gender-specific pinks and blues this was
removed because as we all know there are
officially 99 genders i don't make the
rules just the jokes did you know the
rune language used on kevin the cube was
actually taken from another game
infinity blade an ancient text from
medieval times and did you know where
kevin got his name legend has it that
it's thanks to the fortnite reddit as we
all know moderators are power hungry
losers with an edipus complex suddenly
they decided to ban the word cube
forcing users to change their word one
person started using kevin and now it's
law epic have cancelled a few updates
over the years including new items the
storm tracker backpack was in game for
30 minutes before it was yeted this let
players see the next storm circle to
plan out their rotations that back bling
so happens to be another rare item only
given to founders of save the world the
other fortnight game rose team leader
and the skirmish bling and now
collector's items another abandoned item
was the beehive grenade you heard me
right a nade which spawned bees to sting
your opponents and now i want it more
recently a family guy crossover was
either scrapped after players found
assets in the files or it was
accidentally made public and the real
thing will be coming later in the year
the comic book series crossover between
dc and fortnite had a secret shadowy
character added sama saran from metroid
yet she never came to fortnite or at
least not yet so it's 2022 and
crossovers and cross-platform play is
natural to us all well that always
wasn't the case back in 2017 sony didn't
want their audience mixing with nintendo
xbox or pc somehow epic just made it
happen anyway claiming it was an error
the community loved it and eventually
sony accepted all gamers like to play
together there have been two hidden
minigames in fortnite to find during
chapter 2 a skiing game could be found
on deadpool's computer hidden through an
air vent the second was during downtime
in chapter one by using the famous
konami code we could play a fast food
themed galaxians on release fortnite
battle royale praised pubg for its
inspiration this led to pubg's publisher
to sue epic games for deliberately using
another product to help raise awareness
of their own this dispute was settled
out of court and we still don't know if
any money changed hands this was the
first of many legal battles in epic and
fortnite's history the most noteworthy
was a group of celebrities who attempted
to sue epic for emotes and designs
inspired by them carlton from the fresh
prince knew this emote was all about him
yet his case was rejected after footage
of him was found admitting he stole this
dance anyway this happened all over
again when the backpack had tried it and
it so happens that he stole the floss
from another person too thankfully epic
learned from all this and began paying
artists and making official emotes
instead of taking them without
permission epic have also sued many
people through the years including a 14
year old boy in 2017 who reverse
engineered the fortnite code to find
ways to cheat he then shared them with
the world and generally ruined fortnite
for everyone else in his lobbies when
epic decided to sue apple they did so in
a genius way the video in which bright
bomber breaks the screen is actually a
recreation of an apple advert from the
1980s back then apple was complaining
against big companies controlling the
industry epic decided to show them they
have become the thing they set out to
fight very meta very true during the
epic versus apple case did you know that
one session came down to this guy pili
and if a naked banana was offensive
really how basic is that nobody told
them donald duck doesn't wear any
trousers here's a strange one how long
do you think it took the battle royale
team to make the battle royale game mode
two months that's it just two months
that is wow during the prime of fortnite
it was possible to receive a university
scholarship if you were great at
fortnite four thousand dollars were
given to budding pros to get the
education they need to set up their life
if going pro didn't happen the fortnite
world cup gave away 40 million dollars
but it's not the most ever awarded that
title goes to dota 2 who paid a few
thousand dollars more to reclaim that
mantle the difference is much wider when
the highest paid players are taken into
account fortnite world cup champion
booger received 3.2 million dollars for
his work whereas the dota champ took
home over 7 million dollars wow at the
fortnight world cup did you notice two
players always receiving boos they were
ronaldo and ziff who are dirty dirty
cheating players who served the two-week
ban for cheating but then they were
allowed back in the crowd made sure they
were remembered as cheats so gg crowd
did you know fortnite is canon in three
hugely important franchises firstly it's
played in marvel's avengers a movie set
in the future even though that poi
doesn't exist anymore it's also canon in
star wars the live event in chapter 2
season 1 gave us a monologue from
palpatine as he declares his return from
being thrown down a ventilation shaft a
few decades earlier and thanks to the
recent comic book crossover with batman
the dc world is forever linked to
fortnite so when you're watching
christian bale or playing the arkham
games always remember that in one
timeline that batman came to this island
and escaped the loop it's law it's canon
the original meteor we all expected to
hit tilted towers was confirmed by the
mustard we called donald to have changed
its destination the plan was to smash
tilted but as too many of us expected
that he and his team changed the
location to troll the fan base and
therefore made us expect the unexpected
that meteor eventually landed at dusty
depot yes i say depot and the building
erected around it was designed to look
like the crater where thor lost his
hammer in the movies you know that
hammer that meow meow here's what i'm
sure you know the only person who can
lift thor's hammer in a game of battle
royale is captain america showing that
epic pay attention to the law of other
properties you know the most hated video
on youtube is the rewind of 2018 well
that video has many fortnite references
including ninja being the bus driver and
nick a30 just being all cute and nikkei
30 like oh in it cute did you know
friendly fire was a thing in fortnite up
until march 2018 it was possible to
shoot your own teammates the trolling
got so bad in squad film matches that
epic had to remove it completely another
update which was quickly removed was all
about physics and boobs yeah for a short
period of time this emote caused
calamities fun bags to jiggle i can't
believe i'm saying this so i may as well
continue the save the world version of
penny had her chest covered when moving
to battle royale to make her appearance
less suggestive and more child-friendly
here's a good one when coral castle was
added the code name was shown instead of
its real name carl which is a nod to the
walking dead and how rick grimes
pronounces carl it's kind of like coral
a carl carl
the original long-standing elimination
record for a solo game was set by
elemental rey who broke down a ramp
during the first ever live event to net
himself 48 kills 13 eliminations past
the previous record in chapter 3 the
rock's foundation character has just
become unlocked with this emote and did
you know to allow this epic had to add
two extra bones to the model to allow
the eyebrow to do that and did you know
only 1 in 10 people can raise one
eyebrow on its own
you're trying right now aren't
you me too so how did you do out of 69
what did you get let me know in the
comments and let me know if you'd like a
part two of this because i know at least
another 200 stupid questions i hope you
want more i'm adam you're awesome see ya